I want to start with a sincere congrats
on the movie I thought you did such such
a great job with this
um I really want to know though I read
that you shot this thing in 31 days and
I would really like to know how
and it's a much longer I don't have time
for that but on the very short version
of it I booked very quickly I had my
same DP at Nicholas counts katanas from
itanya and corella I like to work
quickly I but not not at the detriment
of the actors I like the crew to be able
to set up and shoot fast so we knew it
was going to be fast and we'd come in
incredibly prepared it's completely shot
listed because I think this close to 260
scenes or something in this film
and I love that jigsaw puzzle and the
actors are amazing they're phenomenal
so you know they're going to come in
prepared and then we get to play with it
within the scenes that's that's the part
I kind of feel like the speed gives me
that adrenaline to be able to play like
and so we're in the moment of throwing
out lines trying things getting the
script and you know it's such a caliber
of actors that it works great uh one of
the things is when the movie ended I
remembered how angry I was at the time
when Robin Hood people over yes
and all that stuff and you do such a
great job of setting all that up and
reminding people and letting people know
what happened
um can you sort of talk about like what
did you take away from what you learned
about Wall Street and everything that
sort of uh you wish or you hope more
people will know this is I mean I lived
through this experience through my son
who was 24 at the time living with me uh
during covet and my family and uh he was
involved in Wall Street bets from early
on he was playing the options all the
way up until the big ride and he got out
perfectly he timed it perfectly but the
intensity of that period that two-week
window in particular like like watching
like checking every three minutes up at
six a.m checking the market staying up
till 3am at night watching the
aftermarkets in Europe like trying to
figure it all out the flow the
conversations what's happening when are
we going to get out then when it happens
Wall Street beds getting shut down Robin
Hood doing the freeze on the buy option
the outrage and the frustration from the
community and the anger and that fall
out of that and then the Congressional
hearing like I wanted to capture all of
that and I I really want to take the
audience on this ride and be left with
that outrage at the end like that
frustration of feeling like there's a
system that's rigged against them this
disparity of wealth that's going on like
in our country and wanting to be heard
and I just hope it continues that
dialogue and it starts that up and we've
been seeing you know it's happening all
over the place at the moment the strikes
that are going on uh you know in
different in in different areas around
the world and that's something that it's
it's very real and very much a part of
our conversation and is is just growing
yeah I'll say personally not that I'm
some sort of crazy investor but I had
Robin Hood and after what happened with
GameStop I got off the app because I was
so angry that they people over
you and 90 I mean their stocks they went
you know they went public and this stock
is now 90 below what they opened at and
there's a enormous amount of frustration
online with what happened and they
certainly heard so I love talking about
the editing process because it obviously
is where it all comes together so how
did this film change in the editing room
in ways you didn't expect the
interesting thing actually the
interesting thing in the edit was how
much information does the audience need
and the first edit of the film it
explained a lot it got very technical in
places like with what options are and
short sells and what we realized is
it became homework and it's not what the
movie's about it's really this emotional
Journey that I was talking about with
what was frustrating people and also
what's at stake which is their
livelihood it's like people are people
are dealing with sums of money that
would drastically change their lives for
the better or the worse like drastically
like such large sums of money that
they're not used to and that's what the
emotional element of the story is that's
what's at stake and that's you know and
that and and the frustration
so we realized we could take a lot of
that information out and the characters
were telling us what to feel we didn't
need stock shots and explanations that
way we had a wealth of information it's
funny like all the memes all the online
line day Traders talking all the um the
networks that were talking about it the
the late talk show host it's like we
could go to all this wealth of
information to explain things and we
explored that to varying degrees in the
edit and ultimately try to keep it as
concise as possible do you think that in
eventually they'll be on Blu-ray do you
foresee releasing a lot of that stuff or
is it like oh this movie is cut
perfectly well we are very happy with it
that's just it's funny it's like we went
through this Evolution and it's like you
know and then the studio like you know
we I I'm very thorough in my directors
cut and I actually like to start
screening it early so three four weeks
and I started screening it to friends
and family and we get a lot of these
answers so
you know when the studio watches it and
it's like should we explain options more
I'd be like no because when we did this
and we can show them the clip that we
have you know this happened and this
happened and people like you know
started getting bored or lost so you
know and he said we sort of went through
all of those Explorations before we uh
like showed it to people talk a little
bit about like how did you obviously you
got a screenplay that you worked from
but there's so many people that were
involved in this how did you decide
these are the things I want to focus on
and you know because you show all sides
all different sorts of people in the
movie but you know what I mean because
how did you decide on the people you
wanted to focus on you know I I took
that that intensity that I saw from my
son going through this experience you
know and the community
like that I took into the film and the
first thing I was zeroed in on obviously
was Keith Gill with Rory and kitty what
was not and this was happening very fast
this movie obviously it's it's coming
out you know in a very short span from
what the actual event was what wasn't in
the initial script was the Congressional
hearing and
looking at the footage of key skills
seeing him having to testify seeing
like what was at stake for him in that
testimony you know being the only
individual that's that you know
reporting in Congress
that's where that to me was the natural
conclusion of the film and the aftermath
of what didn't didn't happen because of
that
so that part of the film was new and
basically the third Act of the movie
putting that in and once we were
exploring that and the repercussions of
what is setting it out being subpoenaed
what's happening behind closed doors in
their family household like what is he
going to sell not sell all of those
conversations started to percolate like
whether I would work with Paul Dano like
in the six weeks leading up to shooting
and then I would call the Rebecca Angelo
and Lauren shook a bomb and be like okay
we need a scene when he tells his
parents we need a scene when he gets
subpoenaed you know it's like all these
elements and just kept growing and uh
that was really fun to be able to
explore that uh before I run out of time
with you I am a big fan of your work uh
what are you thinking about shooting
once these strike is over I there's
there's actually got a couple projects
I'm very excited about but it's too
early to say so sorry
so I basically got I got uh so you are
planning on making something though oh
yeah yeah okay so jumping back into dumb
money um was it how did you guys come up
with the title for this thing actually
was it always dumb money when it came to
me the the title that Rebecca and Lauren
again it was dumb money there were
conversations about changing it but I I
just loved
the statement that it was making and how
it views the you know the 99
uh in our society so I felt like it was
it was so appropriate for what our
message was one of the things about the
film that I think uh I I do think that
what happened has permanently shifted
Short Selling and because the the Reddit
Wall Street bets these are very smart
people you know what I mean so do you
think this oh I absolutely I feel like
it's it's it's changed the whole dynamic
and you know we've we've seen that it's
like they say that 85 of hedge funds now
have a marketing department watching
social platforms to see what they're
doing because there's a great line that
we put in at the end of the film which
is they were considered a fringe
movement and now they can move markets
and that's the seismic shift that's
happened on that note I gotta go I'm
just gonna say good luck with your speed
dating and congrats on the movie thank
you Steve it's great to see you again